as daniel pink said people fail to
achieve mastery not because they aren't
talented but because they aren't
disciplined the wonderful news about the
human condition is you can get good at
anything that you set your mind to it's
just not going to be easy and it's not
going to be fast
but the willingness to put in that work
is what's going to separate you from
everybody else and i'm begging you to
see yourself right now today as
average
as no better than anyone else
but i beg you with more force then i
know how to convey with this language to
see yourself as malleable to see
yourself as capable of becoming anything
you want to become to become truly
extraordinary if you can find within
yourself the discipline to stick with it
long enough
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation hey it's evan carmichael
and i make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
tom bilyeu and my take on his top 10
rules of success
enjoy
and as steve martin said perseverance
is a great substitute for talent
everybody wants to talk about who's
talented everybody looks at the person
with innate talent as if they have
something magical
but to me
it's a gift it's a handout
it's a freebie it hasn't been earned
and no matter what it is it's only the
beginning even somebody that has talent
even if you get an early win if you let
somebody outwork you if you let somebody
who has more perseverance more grit than
you then they are going to outperform
you on a long enough timeline the only
thing i can guarantee is you will be out
worked by somebody unless you pour your
heart and soul into getting great if you
don't take days off if you put yourself
into it as if your life depended on it
when you act like that
then you've got a chance to be great
and as robert hory said pressure can
bust pipes
but it can also make diamonds
you've got to want that pressure you've
got to want things to be hard you can't
seek out the easy life you can't just
hope and pray that you can uncover
inside of you some talent that's laid
dormant that you didn't know about
that's going to let things be easy for
you don't want the easy want the hard
want the pressure want the thing that's
going to turn you into something
because when it's easy
you don't work for it
when it's easy you don't push when it's
easy you get surpassed by the person who
has to give it their all who's prepared
to do blood sweat and tears in order to
become that thing that they want to be
so badly because they are so [ __ ]
angry that they were never given
anything and with that chip on their
shoulder they're determined to become
anything that they set their mind to
so whether you have talent
whether you don't
the only thing that matters is will you
persevere
will you stick with it long enough to
get great rule number two enjoy the
process some things you
build whether you can control the
outcome or not sometimes it's the
process that is the thing that's meant
to be enjoyed it's the process that
you're meant to invest in and rather
than always thinking about the goal the
outcome or what you're going to get out
of something
focus on the something focus on the part
of it that you can control because you
can't always control the outcome you
can't know what's going to happen
tomorrow tomorrow's not guaranteed to
any of us and yet we all act and yet we
create momentum in our lives when we're
at our best
but we do that not because we can
control every aspect we do that because
we accept that there are things that we
cannot control
and as steve mariboli said
incredible change happens in your life
when you decide to take control of what
you do have power over instead of
craving control
over what you don't
and that's where a lot of people get
lost
they focus not on what they have in
their hands they focus instead on the
things that they can't control it
irritates them it frustrates them it's
like a splinter in their mind they can't
stop thinking about the things that they
don't have control over and they're
blinded to the incredible wealth that is
around them of things that they could
enjoy right here
right
now
that's why gratitude is such an
empowering practice to sit there and not
think of the glorious things may await
you in your future but rather to think
about the things you have here in this
moment
oxygen in your lungs a simple breeze on
your face a window in your house someone
that you love someone that loves you
nothing that costs money nothing that
was the pot of gold at the end of a
glorious rainbow
it's not even about becoming something
extraordinary and waiting for the
results of that
it's simply understanding that the one
thing you can control are your actions
today the choices that you make what you
get to do how you think about yourself
the beliefs you choose to bring into
your life those things you control
and when you understand the power in
acknowledging that control and taking
control and using it
that's when your life is going to begin
to change but first you have to divorce
yourself from being obsessively
interested only in an outcome
if instead you build your self-esteem
you build your pride on pursuit
you build your pride on allowing
yourself to care about something so
deeply that even though tomorrow is not
guaranteed that you're going to plant
your apple tree today that you're going
to love that process because it is the
thing you can control you can control
how you show up you can control how you
play you cannot control how other people
react you cannot control what they think
about you
but you can control what you think about
yourself rule number three believe in
yourself everyone takes the limits of
their own vision for the limits of the
world
arthur schopenhauer
there is all around you right now
the reflections of your world belief
they're so ever present that you don't
even see them all the assumption that
you've made about the world the things
that are possible what you're capable of
who you are the very definition of what
it means to be alive
all of it is completely invisible and
you're mistaking what you have
for what could be
and once you break free of that once you
understand that right now you're a
moment in time and that you have latent
potential and that latent potential can
be expressed in the form of skills that
you can get good at things that you can
develop yourself in any direction that
brain plasticity alone
is one of the greatest weapons that
you're not using but you have to move
beyond what you can perceive today you
have to begin to look beyond that and
see that which doesn't yet exist
and you have to remember
that many of the things that are holding
you down are rules that you don't even
realize are rules and as general douglas
macarthur said you're remembered for the
rules you break
and right now
you're following rules that you don't
even realize exists and some of those
rules are simply what is okay to dream
but i'm here to tell you the power
is in recognizing
that you can do it the power is in
having the arrogance of belief the power
is an understanding that you yes you are
going to be capable of something simply
because you are willing to believe in
yourself and that's the thing it's a
willingness to believe in yourself no
one's going to give it to you even the
people that love you they're not going
to give you that they're incapable of
giving it to you people cannot see past
their limitations and they take them for
truth people actually believe the things
that have stopped them will forever not
only stop them but they will stop other
people how can they hope to give you
anything but limitation
so if you know that if you know that
even the people that love you what
they're handing you is limitation with
the best of the intentions with all the
love in the world
how are you going to break out of that
how are you going to break past those
rules how are you going to fight the
anxiety that inevitably comes your way
when you think about going against the
grain but my friends until you can do
that you can never get beyond the
[ __ ] that limits you if people said
gravity is what it is we never would
have reached escape velocity and yet as
a species we have been able to hurl a
rocket into space get it outside of
gravity take us to other planets that is
real only because somebody said i refuse
to be held down by the most obvious rule
that we have
the one that everybody says is beyond
reproach and that is gravity
but even gravity will break under the
weight of a superior will so recognize
as epitidus said
if you want to improve be content to be
thought foolish and stupid
can you be content to be thought foolish
and stupid
or do you allow yourself to be caged to
be hemmed in by what other people think
and look i get it i understand the sting
of contempt i understand how much it
sucks when someone you respect doesn't
respect you
but you cannot be anything more than
their captive if you think about what
they think about you if you let yourself
be defined by what other people perceive
of as you then you will forever be
limited by what they give you permission
to do
and i don't know about you but when i
was a kid i said when i'm an adult i
will never be told what to do again i
will never be held back by somebody else
i will define myself i will figure out
what i need to do and i will do it and
at the end of the day that is it my
goals drive my behavior i am not held
back by what other people think about me
no matter how
intoxicating it is to be loved
you have to decide what you want more do
you want to be you or do you want to be
someone else's reflection of you rule
number four look for the positive
everything around you
is
incredible if you're willing to look at
it that way everything around you can be
taken for granted if that's your
perspective
but it really is about the frame that
you choose to put around things i mean
simply being alive is already insane the
odds are so stacked against you not only
just being a human but being a human at
this
moment in time this moment in time where
breakthroughs and technology are
happening at
at an unprecedented rate where
breakthroughs in medical science are
happening at an unprecedented rate where
our ability to connect with people to
empathize with people all the way around
the globe all of the changes that have
happened in technology and telecom and
connectivity health everything
we're living in
the most miraculous time ever
but you have to look at it that way
and as joseph campbell said life is a
wonderful wonderful opera
except that it hurts
so the question is do you see it as the
beautiful opera
or do you just pay attention to the pain
and at the end of the day you're going
to get what you focus on they're both
true
this is both the most amazing time
that's ever happened ever in recorded
history
and yet real things that are terrifying
or also happening
but where you put your energy where you
put your attention where you put your
focus is going to determine what you see
and that is the most fascinating and the
most important thing you have to
understand about the way that your mind
works you get what you focus on if you
focus on the things that are bad they
will become real they will become
exaggerated they will begin to
monopolize your thoughts you'll see them
everywhere it's called the reticular
activating system your mind is literally
designed
to pay attention to the things that you
notice
once you notice a certain car you see it
everywhere once you notice a certain dog
you see it everywhere once you hear a
certain name for the first time suddenly
realize that that name has been all
around you this entire time but now that
you're focusing on it now that you're
looking for it it is everywhere
so whatever you look for
it's gonna be everywhere
if you look for the negative it'll be
there but if you look for the positive
it will overwhelm you also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video i've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five get started on your
ideas step number one to accomplishing
whatever it is that you want to do is
actually getting started and i
understand i know the thing that holds
you back i know the thing that is
absolutely
paralyzing for people
is you don't think that you have what it
takes to go out and be good and rather
than face that difficult brutal process
of growing and getting better and quite
frankly facing your inadequacies
it's easier just to sit back but as john
wooden said never let what you cannot do
interfere with what you can there is
something right now that you're capable
of there is an innate skill inside of
you that's your spark it's that starting
point it's that thing that while you may
not be the best in the world at it it's
a flame that you can fan it's something
that you can breathe life into and
really begin to get good but first you
have to understand the very nature of
progress
and that's as stephen covey said
you're not the product of your
circumstances but rather a product of
your decisions and it's those decisions
that are going to allow you to build
that skill set so don't worry about
where you started don't worry about what
you already have remember it's the
decisions that you make it's going down
that road it is
the decision
to get started it's the decision to face
possible failure it's the decision to
get up once you failed and it's the
decision
of what to learn when you fail
do you learn that you're not good enough
do you learn you never should have tried
or do you learn a lesson from the
failure and get up and brush yourself
off and remember that at the end of the
day
you're going to go as far as you're
willing to fight for and that's it if
you're willing to fight to go all the
way then you will go that far you will
set a new bar you will define for people
what
is possible
you become that beacon of hope and
become that thing that other people look
to as the standard
but at the end of the day it started
with you getting started it started with
you showing up it started with you
pushing and trying
so get out there
don't worry about
what you have and what you are
focus on who you want to become
and the price you're willing to pay to
get there rule number six pursue what
matters as vaclav haval said
work for something because it is good
not just because it stands a chance to
succeed
this is something that i think a lot of
people misunderstand they think that the
goal of their life is to identify
something that'll work to identify
something that has the odds stacked in
its favor
rather than to think about
what matters
what's important
because if something is important if it
speaks to you if it's going to
give resonance to your life then it's
worth doing even if it's something that
is almost guaranteed to fail when
something matters enough regardless of
the odds it's worth engaging with
because even in the pursuit
you can find meaning and as humans one
of the things that we hunger for most is
purpose and meaning but you can't have
that purpose and meaning without the
thing that you're pursuing be something
that you believe to be worthwhile so
don't worry about whether or not it
succeeds ask only about whether or not
it's going to light you on fire ask only
if in those dark moments that it will
give you that sense of mattering to this
world that even in the failure do you
learn something about yourself do you
see
the truth
that you matter
and that even as a single person even as
one individual you can echo through this
world
but that will never happen by pursuing
something small
that will never happen by pursuing
something simply because it can win
it will only happen by pursuing
something that matters
and in that if you pursue something that
matters and you're able to get to the
point where you can see it across the
finish line or at least advance it and
make it a step closer to becoming real
in that we realize how societies really
are transformed in that and trying the
big the impossible dreaming that thing
that nobody else is even willing to talk
about in dreaming that it is the crazy
ones who are able to change the world
because the crazy ones allowed
themselves to believe
they allowed themselves to believe that
against all the odds a world that does
not yet exist could actually exist
and as ralph marston said welcome those
big sticky complicated problems in them
are your most powerful opportunities and
that's it the big problems the ones that
matter the things that will give you
purpose and meaning in your life they're
going to be hard but if you can look at
the hard things and show up and push
every day and keep striving and when you
fall down pick yourself back up and
focus only on one thing not whether or
not you're going to win but whether or
not it mattered that you played
if you do that
every sacrifice in your life will be
worth it
and if not
[Music]
nothing you gain
will have mattered rule number seven
know your why this is why jocko willing
says discipline is freedom when you know
i don't go outside of these lines i
don't break these rules these rules are
hard and fast they are bright lines now
there's no you know maybe i should maybe
i shouldn't it's like me and getting out
of bed in 10 minutes or less i never
want to every single day literally every
day of my life
my brain is kicking up excuses why today
i shouldn't have to get out of bed and
10 minutes less even i am startled that
after i've been doing this now for more
than 20 years even
20 years in
i still
have to fight every day but i have
bright lines so there's no excuse so
literally when i think oh well today you
don't have to for xyz reasons
my conscious mind i've repeated it so
many times is this is a bright line
there are no excuses there is no reason
there is no if ands or buts you get out
of bed in 10 minutes or less full stop
period end of story
and so therefore i get out of bed but
you have to know what you're striving
for you have to know why you're doing
all of this why you're putting in all
these rules and it has to be something
you're actually interested in you're
actually excited about otherwise why why
are you limiting your life like this why
are you narrowing things down okay why
not go get the dopamine hit from the
fridge you have to have a reason
right you've got to know why you eat a
certain way or don't eat a certain way
you've got to know why you're working
this hard you've got to know why you
push through the difficult things okay
nietzsche's quote the person
with the right why can survive almost
anyhow okay you have to know what your
why is you've got to know why you're
pushing through all this stuff but once
you have that
you'll be able to slap some rules on
this and get to the other side rule
number eight attempt the impossible as
thomas edison said
our greatest weakness lies in giving up
the most certain way to succeed is to
always try
one
more time
i know there are going to be a million
times in your life where you want to
give up where you absolutely ache with
the desire to quit where nothing sits
inside of your gut other than the
certainty that you are going to fail
that you are not good enough to push
forward but that is to fundamentally
misunderstand the nature of a failure
the nature of a failure is not to tell
you who you are
the nature of a failure is to tell you a
way that didn't work it's to inform it's
to educate you
it's to test you it's to be a gut check
to find out if you believe in yourself
enough to push forward even when the
world seems to be telling you not to
and as brian tracy said
attempt the impossible
in order to improve your work
think about that for a second attempt
the impossible just to get better to try
the things that you know are going to
fail things that the world is going to
tell you simply cannot be but even if it
violates the laws of physics if there's
something in that attempt that you're
going to learn you owe it to yourself
you have a moral obligation
to try
because all of the people that will lie
in your wake are the people that didn't
try simply because they didn't believe
that they could do it
you have to be willing to look at the
world you have to be willing to
see things that you yourself think are
impossible and try because in that you
will stretch yourself you have to be
willing to look inward at the state of
your current skill set and say i'm going
to play outside of that i'm not going to
play word safe i'm going to play where
it hurts i'm going to play where i feel
clumsy i'm going to play only in the
areas that make me feel stupid because
in that i know that the way that the
brain responds is through adaptation but
i have to stress
myself you can't ever lose sight of that
the only way that the human animal
adapts is through stress
you have to be willing to break things
in order to build something new
so if you want to push the boundaries if
you want to see just how far you can go
if you want to succeed at the highest
level if you want to play on a global
scale you have got to be willing to try
the impossible because right now
the things that you need to do are
impossible for you
but they won't remain that way forever
and as aristotle said
pleasure in the job
puts perfection in the work
this doesn't have to be a tale of always
being terrified everybody myself
included screaming at you telling you
that you need to go do something great
the part they're leaving out is why the
should you care
you should care because it's the
greatest joy
you should only listen to this
if it's leading you down a path that
makes you feel more alive and that's the
point the point is to get in touch with
something that makes you feel great but
not to let yourself starve or be stopped
by a fear that you'll fail
by a fear that it can't be done
have fun have the guts to enjoy yourself
have the guts to go out and attempt
something audacious and terrifying
knowing that all along if you're doing
it right
you're gonna have a good time
so all of this going balls out trying to
prove something to yourself trying to do
something amazing
never lose sight
that it's to build a better life
never lose sight of the fact that you're
doing it
to create
the person that you want to be never
lose sight of the fact
that it should be fun rule number nine
always be learning the most powerful
weapon that you're going to have at your
disposal isn't a gun it isn't a sword it
isn't a bomb the most powerful weapon
you will ever have at your disposal if
you really want to make change
is knowledge
it doesn't mean going to school it can
be school it can be books it can be a
mentor it can be somebody else's failure
it can be your own
failure
but whatever it is to always be learning
to be learning something today knowing
that that's an investment and as robert
louis stevenson said don't
judge each day by the harvest you reap
but rather by the seeds you plant and
that's what knowledge is that's what the
learning process is is you're learning
something today that you may not even
understand how it's going to be valuable
but one day
that piece of knowledge is going to come
to your aid one day that thing that you
learned is going to be something that
you're going to lean on one day that
thing that you've worked your ass off to
understand better than anybody else in
the world
it's going to help you change
the world
but you have to be doing it now you have
to be learning with an obsession you
have to understand that ideas in equal
ideas out and that you have to chase
that knowledge down that it is a
relentless pursuit and that like you
would build an armada like you would
create a stock pile of weapons you must
create a stockpile of knowledge you must
learn and learn and learn and you must
hold yourself accountable every day to
planting those seeds to getting better
to learning more to understanding things
more broadly when you do that there will
be nothing that won't be unlocked to you
that's what i want you guys to
understand it doesn't matter where you
are now it doesn't matter where you
started your circumstances the money the
people that you know none of it
matters what matters is how much are you
willing to learn how good are you
willing to get how much knowledge are
you willing to soak in because that
will become your weapon that will be how
you rise up and that will be the thing
that will protect you when you need it
most annual number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus clips is
be unique as zen she says flower does
not think about competing with the
flower next to it it just blooms and
that's really your job is to see the
outside world to see the flower next to
you to understand the amazing things
that are happening all around you all of
the incredible people and the essence of
what they have and what it is that
they've done to bring inside yourself
and find out what does that look like
when it's me
not what do i look like when i'm them
and once you understand the difference
between that then you can really begin
to be something unique you can become
that thing that you were meant to be
that thing that makes you feel alive and
whole and that's it that's the secret
you're just trying to be something not
that's just inspiring to other people
but that you actually want to wake up
every day and be and that's the thing
about it
so escaping you
whatever you become a lie the truth
somebody else yourself whatever it is
you spend every
day of your life there
here is a reality no matter how
successful the person is that you're
looking at and wishing you could be like
them and thinking that they have
everything all figured out the one thing
that i can promise you is that all of us
struggle on the inside that is just a
reality of the human condition once you
understand that that is a reality that
that's just a part of the human
condition then you can begin to ideally
let yourself off the hook and that
you're not spending a lot of time
stuck there but to give you a specific
example from my life the biggest one the
most harrowing one that i went through
was in film school so
uh
to cut a very long story short i went to
film school believed that i had innate
talent i went into film school with a
fixed mindset
i did very well at the beginning of film
school and that all to me felt like it
was proof that i was right that i was
naturally gifted that i was a born
storyteller and that i was going to go
and have an illustrious career and i
actually went through a fascinating
period in film school where i was both
terrified that secretly i wasn't good
enough and but at the same time actually
believed that i was naturally gifted and
this is what i was meant to do and every
bit of feedback that i got in either
direction was
it made me believe to the core of my
being that it was true so when i would
do something poorly i would think see
that part of me that was convinced that
i actually don't have talent you were
right and then i would do something well
and the part of me that believed that
was like see i knew it you were born for
this
and it all came crashing down as i work
my way up the ranks at usc film school
only four people are chosen to direct
what's known as a senior thesis film or
a 480. and i was one of the four people
picked and i was like see i knew it man
i'm born for this of course i got picked
to do one of the senior thesis films
that just makes sense i'm i'm that good
and i thought okay cool the thing that
makes the thesis film so important is
the film school pays your budget to make
this film so at a time where there's no
youtube there's no iphones like filming
is an expensive endeavor
here you've got somebody that's paying
for it and that becomes your calling
card to the industry so george lucas
famously made one of these films and
obviously we know how his career ended
up working out and they showed us his
480 by the way and it was amazing
it was amazing and so
you could see that here was this gifted
filmmaker
and so i have that in my head like look
at george lucas's films absolutely
brilliant he's gone on to have this
brilliant career i'm gonna make an
equally brilliant film or maybe a little
more brilliant and then i'm gonna go
become the next lucas or the next
spielberg and i'm gonna take that film
and get my three picture deal
and
i proceeded to
run smack bang
into one immutable truth
and that was that i wasn't a talented
filmmaker
and i don't say that to be humble i say
that out of truth because i didn't have
the skill set to make a good film once
the level of complexity had gone beyond
a certain level so i had thrived in
these really short really simple films
and then once you're talking actors and
dialogue and you know the things that
would come close to what we would
recognize as a normal film uh
i had no idea what i was doing
and
try and try as i might i couldn't figure
out how to make the film come out well
and it didn't come out well and i was
mortified and i was embarrassed and i
never wanted anybody to see that film
and i was really and truly devastated so
i want you to imagine your whole life so
what i graduated at like 22. so
from 12 to 22
all i knew was i wanted to be a
filmmaker and my whole life was moving
towards that and it looked like i had
the natural gift and of course if you're
going to be an artist you're either born
with it or you're not right that's all
anybody said i can't express enough
in the 80s and 90s when i grew up
when people talked about art you either
had it or you didn't and that was that
there was no sense of growth mindset
carol dweck had not written the book yet
and so it wasn't even like i knew there
was a growth mindset and a fixed mindset
i just knew you're either born with it
or you're not
the great news was i was born with it
here we go it's going to be amazing and
then boom i can't do it and i realize oh
my god i wasn't born with anything
i don't know how to do this there is a
tremendous amount of process to this art
and i don't know that at all but of
course as i'm in the middle of it i just
think my world has come crashing down
i'm not gifted i will never be gifted
and therefore i will never be a
filmmaker i will never make anything of
myself and just it was a downward spiral
of epic proportions
and
at the height of that
i would go home from my dead-end job
and i would lay
face down
on the carpet because i couldn't afford
furniture
and
literally just sit there i can still
feel
that cheap nylon carpet and the way that
it felt on my face
as i laid there thinking well
my life is effectively over certainly
the my life that was working towards a
dream is over
and
now it's just about finding a way to
be the smartest person in the room
and if that means that i have to go and
work a dead-end job to be the smartest
person in the room then that's what i'll
do and so i used to go
and interview for jobs having nothing to
do with film
because i felt totally broken and
my goal was to at some point in the
interview have the interviewer say
you're so smart why are you interviewing
for this role
and because i had a fixed mindset and i
so needed that praise from the outside i
was putting myself in these super weird
and useless positions just to get that
little nugget of oh my god like you're
so smart
and i had to put myself in sort of worse
and worse company to get to that point
and
finally and i don't remember what it was
that
led me to this idea of brain plasticity
but somewhere in the depths of my
despair i realized
can we get better maybe we can
and so i started reading about the brain
and that started to plant seeds in my
mind that maybe brain plasticity was
real and maybe i could get better and
just because i wasn't good at film today
maybe i could get better at film down
the road and i ended up getting a job
teaching film because remember those
that can do those that can't teach so i
felt like okay well i can teach this
even if i can't do it
and then so between reading about the
brain and realizing wait a second
if i work at this thing i actually get
better my brain actually changes and i
become better at something and
given you know having gone through
however many years of schooling i'd been
through i started thinking about like
wait a second you would come into any
class and the funny thing is as a kid i
remember every grade just being
absolutely terrified that well i did
okay being a fourth grader but mom i'm
gonna get devastated as a fifth grader i
don't know what i'm doing and no matter
how many times my mom would console me
and say remember they're going to teach
you
how to learn the things that a fifth
grader needs to know they don't expect
you to already know it it just wouldn't
sink in and so i was sort of back in
that moment of
you know i don't know how to do this
but maybe
my mom is right maybe the
neuroscientists are right and maybe i
can learn
to become that thing i want to become i
start teaching film
and as i'm teaching it i realize wait
i'm helping my students become better
filmmakers so if i can help them become
better filmmakers and brain plasticity
is really true then i could get better
as a filmmaker myself
and that
that realization changed the rest of my
life and this is why i
am so obsessed with the idea of
a growth mindset and brain plasticity
because the biology backs it up
and once you understand it's what i call
the only belief that matters the only
belief that matters is that if you put
time and energy
into getting better at something you'll
actually get better can you describe
what you mean by going into the darkness
i can
all right so going into the darkness i
think everybody is motivated by two
different things one you have the
beautiful things in your life
the things that are going well the
things that you're grateful for the
things you're moving towards instead of
a way you have a compelling vision of
your future it's something that you're
very excited about
all of those things are the beautiful
things now the flip side of that
equation are the
things that uh it's people that doubt
you it's haters it's um things you're
moving away from it's fear-based things
it's something that you absolutely
refuse to let happen so one that is
incredibly potent to me are the people
that want to see me fail so it's very
different than people who just think
you're going to fail i actually don't
have a lot of um
aggression towards people like that but
people that want me to fail
those people i have a lot of aggression
for and i find in very acute moments
the darkness serves you better
in very acute moments now the light the
things you're moving towards the things
that are beautiful the things that
you're grateful for all of that is the
only winning strategy long term because
the darkness becomes corrosive you start
to become bitter you start to be angry
you stop being optimistic you stop
seeing things in a way that's empowering
and positive and i mean just thinking
about the deep limbic system when it
gets inflamed you perceive things as
negative i think negativity stops people
from making progress there's a whole
host of neurological reasons and sort of
mindset reasons why i think that being
negative over the long run becomes very
very detrimental and holds you back but
from an acute standpoint they've done
studies on this if you want someone to
be able to endure more pain the surest
way to get people to endure more pain is
to let them get angry let them be
aggressive and in doing that
people are able to withstand in the
clinical trials i'll say there's
probably more than this but in clinical
trials they're able to withstand 30
percent more pain so just straight being
able to take more pain anger and
aggression lets you do 30 more so
that's why i think in acute ways and
short term bursts that the darkness will
serve you
once you accept
that the thing that separates you from
the rest of the animal kingdom
is an unimaginable ability to become
you have an
unimaginable ability to become something
in 2014 private companies averaged eight
percent annual growth
after i went into my partners and i said
i quit
and i'm gonna go do something that makes
me feel alive they were totally shocked
and i got all the way to my house and i
was on the phone with my wife i did it
i had been unhappy for so long
and i said i did it i told him i quit i
gave back the equity here i am and i'm
pulling into the driveway at my house
and my phone rings
and it's my partners
they say come out to dinner with us
out of respect and love i went out to
dinner with them
and they said the now famous words
we could do this without you
but we don't want to
and that gave me what i needed to
connect to something other than money
it reminded me of the brotherhood it
reminded me that i had fallen in love
with these guys as human beings that
there was something more than money
there was something more than being a
clever marketer
that i remembered for a second who i am
the things that make me unique
that i have a desire to connect that i
actually enjoy communities that i'm not
a guy with a killer instinct i'm not
interested in stepping on my cons my
competitor's necks this just not how i'm
wired
i'm wired to build something i'm wired
to see people shine i love seeing other
people win i think it's incredible now
that doesn't mean that i don't want to
win i want to win at the absolute
highest level i want to be the greatest
of all time
i want more people to write about me
going to mars because they're terrified
to try to match my intros
i want that right and i hope each and
every one of you wants to play at that
level i hope each and every one of you
looks at the greatest of all time and
says if i'm willing to break myself and
have to get there i could do it
but being honest with who you are being
honest that if there's something else
that you want to bring to the table that
you find a way to do that and so i said
guys i will come back and work with you
on one condition
i will never
prioritize money again
my highest value in business is
camaraderie
and at the time that was sacrilege we
had made a pact with each there was
three of us the three of us had made an
actual pact that we would do whatever it
took to make our technology company more
profitable and if that meant skipping a
family vacation if that meant waking up
at 2 a.m on a saturday to meet and
brainstorm we did it
both of those stories are real we did
things like that i would go away with my
wife for christmas to see her family in
london and i would literally take a
camera with me so i could watch
the company
back in la
i've never switched off i didn't take
days off i was working no matter where i
was i was working seven days a week i
didn't take a real vacation meaning that
i wasn't actually working while we were
on it for six and a half years
never
give up
on what you really want to do
the person with big dreams is more
powerful than the person with all the
facts
h jackson brown
words have never been spoken it is one
of the most interesting things about the
human condition
that all of the facts in the world no
matter how true something may
objectively really be the only thing
that matters is whether or not you've
got the energy to see through to the end
of what you want to do and the energy
comes not from truth
the energy comes from your dream the
energy comes from what it is that you
want to do
the energy ultimately is born out of
what you want to create it's born out of
a willingness
to allow yourself to dream it's born out
of a willingness to think that you
actually can do it it's born out of a
willingness to take that first step but
the only reason that you're going to
take that first step is you believe that
you can actually make your dreams come
true and that sense of this thing that
you have in your mind that you can make
it real that you can bring it into the
real world and have that excitement that
you've long fantasized about and
understand and really feel in your gut
[Applause]
that that thing that you've dreamed
about can be real and when you have that
that's when you're going to have the
energy that you need to push
and to fight and to go through all of
the difficult things that you're going
to have to to get on the other side and
make that dream real
as ferdinand fox said
the most powerful weapon on earth is the
human soul on fire
but the human soul can't be on fire
without a dream a human soul is not fed
by facts a human soul is fed instead by
a belief that it can accomplish what it
wants to accomplish it's fed by that
thing that idea that you've had in your
mind that you fanned those flames of
interest and turned it into a real
fascination and fan those flames further
into excitement and allowed yourself to
truly embody
that belief
that you can make it happen
so right now whatever it is whatever
crazy dream you have and we all have one
stop judging yourself for it stop
telling yourself that you can't do it
and understand when you cultivate that
fire when you take that little ember and
you fan it into a raging inferno that
that thing that human soul on fire is
what's going to allow you to build
something
that the world has never seen before
but it starts with that dream it starts
with your willingness to cultivate that
to think about it to allow yourself to
do that because so many people stop
themselves they think they're inadequate
they think that they could never
do it
and even if that is a fact
it's not something that's going to help
you live a life that excites you it's
not something that's going to help you
excite other people
the one thing that will do that
is the dream
so right now
allow yourself that
simply to dream if grit is as important
as we say it is
sustained interest over time that's
really what grit is
and a lot of people talk about in fact
the title of my speech is supposed to be
about how you develop a passion which we
will talk about in a little bit but this
is going to be one of those things
when you have passion
one of the things that comes out of that
is you've got the ability to sustain
your interest over time do the hard
things
do the hard things
i can't emphasize that one enough
put yourself in uncomfortable situations
just to find the mental tactics that
you're going to need
to deal with
the hard things
it's getting those tactics who knows the
stanford marshmallow test
all right for those of you that don't
this is one of the most breathtaking
examples of the human condition in the
stanford marshmallow test they bring in
i don't know they're five or six years
old they bring them in and the person in
the white lab coat says here's a
marshmallow i'm gonna go out of the room
for a minute i'll be back in just a few
minutes if you wait till i come back
i'll give you a second marshmallow so
essentially double your money
not bad
now what the kid doesn't know is the
researchers never coming back and all
they want to know is how long will you
wait before you eat the marshmallow some
kids have literally gobbled it up before
they even get to the door
other kids are like singing to
themselves putting their head down
getting up dancing around the room some
of them bite like the underside and try
to put it back so you can't see
and here's what's scary
they followed those kids for 25
years
and based solely on
the length of time they were able to
wait before they ate the marshmallow
predicted their level of success in
school
predicted their level of success in the
job market the people who waited the
longest got into the best schools got
the best grades went on to have the
highest paying jobs
just your ability to delay gratification
your ability to find tactics that work
to get your mind off something
there's no greater control than control
over one's self
anybody here ever done a three day water
only fast
not intermittent fasting
three days
do it
you will learn something about yourself
and it will be profound and what you're
gonna learn
is that your body
is
manipulative
and i did a three-day fast just a couple
weeks ago
and i had the flu right before so there
were cough drops laying around
and every time i walked by those cough
drops
my brain was like eat one
and i was like
you're like
you know i'm fasting
and i literally couldn't believe like
how consistently every time i walk by
those damn cough drops
that my body like gave me this really
intense impulse
and that's when i realized like the
notion that there are multiple voices in
your head by the way is very very real
and i will give you one quick example
who knows what the corpus callosum is
all right the corpus callosum is the
thick bit of tissue that connects the
left and right hemisphere of your brain
if you
sever that you will get people that have
literal multiple personalities one in
the right one on the left some of the
most intriguing stuff is one of them
will be devoutly religious and the other
will be devoutly atheist
in the same brain and you can talk to
them differently
it's absolutely crazy
but the multiple voices notion is real
there are multiple
factions if you will pieces that your
brain is broken up into and by the way
you have the equivalent of a cat's brain
in neurons just in your digestive tract
so the whole notion of gut instinct
think of all the cool cats can do
and you've got that
in your digestive tract neurons
it's literally the same material that
your brain is made out of is in your
digestive tract utterly fascinating so
we have all these competing things that
we want
but inside if you think of that
overwatch that one person that's you
that's meant to say i have goals and i'm
going to act in accordance with my goals
i'm never going to sell out what i want
most for what i want right now i wanted
a cough drop right now but i wanted to
get on the other side of the three-day
fast and say i did it
and i wanted that more
and in learning what your tools and
tactics are so for me i welcome hunger
like an old friend and i literally
people must think i'm schizophrenic
because you'll walk into the room and
i'll literally be like pinching and
poking at my fat
going
hunger thank you i'm so glad you made it
back it is so good to see you i'm glad
you're here i know that you're oxidizing
my fat i'm very grateful for that so
thank you and in doing that i reframe it
not as something that is unwanted or
painful but as something that is doing
exactly what i want it to do
and learning those mental tactics that's
the game
learning those mental tactics that's the
game that's how you're going to get good
at whatever it is you want to do if you
want to start a business learning how to
deal with your employees is absolutely
critical but let me tell you right now
if you lash out emotionally your
employees will lose respect for you
but it's just like the cough drop moment
now if somebody had seen me walk by the
cough drop they wouldn't know that i had
it literally had to
stop myself from lunging at a cough drop
they didn't know that because i have
control of myself
i've practiced things like that i do
three-day fast i do what i call bright
lines
so i have a bright line
during the week
i don't eat my second meal before 11 30.
under any circumstance
my wife one time brought my food 30
minutes early i was preparing for an
episode it was so sweet of her
but i don't eat before 11 30 under any
circumstance so the food literally sat
on my lap
smelling so good
and i was so hungry
and i said
hunger thank you so much
for showing up because you're giving me
the opportunity to prove to myself
what a badass i am
cause i'm gonna smell how delicious you
are knowing my stomach is grumbling and
tying itself in knots because i want to
eat so badly
and i'm not going to
and in those moments you earn
credibility with yourself
i hate working out
absolutely despise it it's why i do it
first thing in the morning
and the reason i hate it the weights are
heavy
and your muscles start burning when you
get to the supposed good
reps
so that just seems backwards
so it is not in any way shape or form
fun for me
but i earn credibility with myself
because it is something that i don't
like
i earn credibility with myself showing
up every day and it also reminds me how
much i can transform my body it's very
easy for me to show you my before and
after picture i used to be 60 pounds
heavier it's very easy for me to show
you when i was heavy and then show you
six pack abs you get it but what you
don't see is the body is just a
reflection of the mind
what really happened
was i changed my mind and i had garnered
skills i had garnered tactics the things
that allowed me to not eat the coffee
drop were the things that allowed me to
not eat the things that i wanted to not
have a bowl of ice cream to not indulge
in things that are
wonderfully delicious but instead ask
myself what are my goals and then back
in with my behaviors as walt disney said
if you can dream it
you can do it
now what makes me laugh as i know right
now some of the people listening to that
they say that's [ __ ]
they're just limits to what humans can
do
[Music]
and i get that response i understand it
i used to respond to everything like
that i used to see only the difficulty i
used to see only the ways in which it
couldn't work out and i couldn't see i
was literally blinded by fear i was
blinded by some bizarre sense of pride
that wanted to justify my limited
existence that didn't want to have to
face that i could be doing more that i
couldn't be more that my life was
somehow less
than what it could be
and so i would laugh at quotes like that
and i know right now of the chills i
know right now
there are people that are laughing at
that and all they can think about are
the limits all they can think about are
the things that prove him wrong and
guess what
he is wrong
there really are limits
but if you
waste your time focused on that you're
never going to create the momentum that
you need to actually make something come
true in your life you can build
virtually anything but if you get hung
up on the virtual part if you let that
stop you if you
immediately go to the things that
ultimately limit you and hold you back
that is where you're gonna stay forever
because if you argue for your
limitations guess what my friend they
become
yours
and congratulations you now get to live
in that box you get to live in that
self-defined prison but if like teddy
roosevelt said instead of that you keep
your eyes on the stars and your feet on
the ground and you don't act like
somebody who can't see that sure there
are limits there are edges to this
universe
but you're looking not at that
you're looking at how do you really
execute you're dreaming big and you're
remembering that your feet ultimately is
that contact point it is where the
rubber meets the road it is that moment
of doing
and so if instead of rejecting it
because your feet must stay planted on
the ground remember that in keeping your
feet on the ground that's the moment of
action that's the moment of doing
something about it that's the moment of
seeing the possibilities and then
moving
doing something
making it real so right now give up on
those weird mental mechanisms that make
you actually want to fight for the
things that aren't possible to get
people to believe in it to get people to
understand why
you've chosen to stand still
instead of that convince yourself that
you should be moving and go do what you
know you're destined to do
have very clear goals it always freaks
me out most people stop at the first
sort of vague notion of what they want
to do i'm going to punch myself in the
mouth if somebody comes up to me again
and says i want to help people
that's rad that comes from a beautiful
place like i totally get it but that's
like coming to me and saying i want to
win an olympic gold medal awesome winter
or summer
summer fantastic swimming or tennis
swimming excellent
backstroke
freestyle like at some point it's got to
get so specific because you have to know
what skills you need to acquire you have
to work backwards from the goal and the
goal has to be hyper specific so if
boredom is the number one killer of
entrepreneurs that they're not able to
make it through the next one is they
don't have clear goals and the worst
part is they think they do
that's the part that terrifies me the
worst part is they think they do
until you know
exactly what your mission is and exactly
what your business model is and what
problem you solve what very concrete
problem that people are freaking out to
have solved until you do that you don't
have the necessary ingredients to build
your business
all right don't be romantic be pragmatic
look at the data the data will tell you
what to kill the data will tell you
what's working and what's not
this was the single best piece of advice
that was ever given to me and i ignored
it for three years i'm so embarrassed by
that that i always make sure any talk i
give people hear this
know more about your product service
industry
whatever than anyone else
than anyone else
if you guys have ever seen my interview
show
the reason that it's doing as well as
it's doing
is i know more about the guest
one guest actually said this i know more
about the guest than their mother
i just put in more work than their
mother
that's the truth
i go out and i research and i read
everything and i watch every video that
i can and so i know so much about that
person i know i'm gonna give a different
interview than anyone has ever given
before because nobody's done that level
of research not only does it blow the
guest away and totally endear them to me
but it gets us to the point where we can
give an interview that has unique value
so know more about what you're doing
than anyone else in the world and grind
baby grind for two years for two years
that's what i look like every day
hair net lab coat gloves
put in the work
put in the work and this is where the
rubber meets the road this is where
you're really going to separate
the people that
are entrepreneurs from the people that
are real entrepreneurs you've got to
want to grind you've got to learn to
love that you've got to learn to love to
put in the work to be proud of yourself
that you showed up and put in the work
to be proud of yourself that you taught
yourself how to suffer to be proud of
yourself that you're developing a
mindset where you believe i can do
anything i set my mind to and by the way
once you believe
that you can do anything you set your
mind to without limitation how you spend
your time
becomes a spiritual consideration
how you spend your time becomes a
spiritual consideration because you
could be doing something if you want to
end hunger
and hunger
what's stopping you bill gates is
actually going to end malaria he's going
to do it because he had the tenacity to
generate the resources and because he
has a mind that allows him to work on
the infrastructure and figure out how to
actually solve that problem
do not under any circumstances make bill
gates or anyone else extraordinary to
let yourself off the hook
don't do it don't sell yourself short
and this is where i see people go wrong
all the time they look at somebody who's
amazing
and they say well
they're just naturally gifted
i could never do that
you couldn't do it because you believe
you can't and because you believe you
can't you don't start putting in the
work
michael jordan got cut from his high
school basketball team
he wasn't exactly showing all the
promise in the world my own mother when
i left for college quietly assumed i was
going to fail and didn't admit that for
years
i showed no early signs of promise
i actually have a version of this
talk where i show photos from my
childhood and people like yeah you just
look stupid
and it's true i used to dress like a
clown and i mean that almost literally
so my waist was size 36 and i wore a
size 54 pants
i wore literal jester hats
i had one of those big chains that
connected to my belt
i had shoulder length hair
i did not exactly
look the part and i didn't take myself
seriously
it really is a game of transformation it
really is a game of understanding that
you can become something so even though
i didn't start with the requisite skills
even though i wasn't a born entrepreneur
which is why i start this tale with that
even though i wasn't a born entrepreneur
i could acquire and did acquire the
skills that were needed to execute
it is a very long road
that leads you here
right now
most entrepreneurs in the world are
thinking about one thing
winning a championship ring as bruce lee
said if you always put limits on
everything you do physical or anything
else it will spread into your work and
into your life there are no
limits
there are only plateaus and you must not
stay there
you must go beyond them
even in the statement you can see him
making a choice about what to believe by
saying that there are no limits by
taking something that other people
perceive as a limit it's something
that's stopping him and saying that's
not it's a plateau it's something that i
can push through and you see what he
holds himself accountable to
it's not okay to stay at a plateau
it's okay to have one everybody has them
they happen it's a natural part of the
course of getting better but it is not
okay to stay there and that is a choice
that's not something anyone can hand you
it's something you have to believe to
the core of your soul that it is not
okay
to stay in a plateau and it's that
that's gonna push you through it's that
that's gonna make you get up and keep
going but first
you have to recognize that life is cause
and effect you have to recognize that
that choice is a knock on effect you
have to recognize that him merely saying
those words out loud
have a cause and effect
they change the course of his life the
expectations that other people have of
him expectations that he has of himself
and because he understands that he can
control
the outside world by first controlling
what's inside by changing his belief
system to match what he wants to
accomplish
he's then able to accomplish
what he did in his life had nothing to
do with luck
it had everything to do with the demands
that he made on himself it had to do
with when he got in a motorcycle
accident people told him he would never
walk again not only did he walk again
all of the major accomplishments that we
think about of being that man
they all came after they came after he
was told he was never going to walk came
after he was told that he was never
going to be able to do martial arts
but he did it he did the grueling work
of getting better he understood cause
and effect he understood that if he
chose to believe
that he could never do it
that he'd never be able to do it
but that if he chose to believe that by
working out he could get stronger and
get better and get back to it than he
could and that's what he did
so now ask yourself
is your life dictated by luck
or cause and effect
are you in control or is it somebody
else
is someone else in control
or is it you
and if it's you
go build the life that you want because
there's nothing stopping you but you
sticking with your good habits is
extremely hard because they're boring so
whenever something is boring it's
because somebody's pursuing something
that they actually don't give a [ __ ]
about and that's the problem so for
instance eating healthy food all the
time is
isn't
thrilling in the way that say eating a
bag of oreos is or black licorice which
is a personal favorite of mine or fried
food which is truly my weakness that
stuff is fun man if you want to talk
about a dopamine cascade i could take a
random tuesday and make it feel like a
saturday night just by deciding that i'm
going to cheat on my diet
now i don't do that
i cheat maybe twice a year
so it is when i say it is crazy rare and
yet my life is full of things that
thrill me and i use that word on purpose
now what it comes back to is going back
to the whole topic of today habits and
how you stick with them even when you're
bored even when it's not interesting
anymore long after it stopped being fun
the very secret to habits is caring
about the thing that that habit is meant
to lead to but for real like really what
do you care about and for instance here
is a life i pass no judgment on man
because if this is what you want
and it like you love it and you're
filled with fulfillment it's amazing
great if you want to sit at home all day
and you want to cut your life to the
absolute quick financially so that
you're living in
a tiny hovel with five other people
fine and you're eating tina's burritos i
don't even know if they still exist but
when i was way hardcore poor they were
awesome because it was three for 99
cents which was amazing
so i could live off of that
and you're cool you boil it down to
nothing you don't have a car no
insurance nothing and you accept that my
life is gonna be shorter than it would
otherwise be and what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna smoke weed a lot and i'm going
to eat bad food a lot man respect like
if you do it with your eyes wide open
and you're loving it and you're having a
great time it just the only reason that
you never hear me talk about that stuff
is from my experience from what i've
seen of other people the only thing that
gives the human animal the
the best feeling which is to feel good
about yourself when you're by yourself
is to do the hard things
and to do things that bring fulfillment
and the things that bring fulfillment
are often born of momentary suffering
but they allow you to get stronger in
order to serve other people that's it
that's just what i've seen so i don't
think it's better than the alternative
that i just described it's just the only
thing that i've seen really lead to that
sense of like
deep fulfillment so
my thing about the the specific part
about the good habits are hard to stick
with because they're boring just you've
got to attach habits to things you
actually really and truly care about no
one can tell you what to care about you
can certainly build that into your life
you can take something that's an
interest and build it into something you
care deeply about uh which i've talked
endlessly about so i won't go into it
here but that is very very possible
associate your habits to that thing
suddenly the habits will be very easy
don't judge yourself live your life the
way you want
but respect the realities of
neurochemistry i don't think people
really realize we construct our lives
we build them from nothing we decide
what our goals are we decide in what way
to move we
decide who we're going to become and
what we're going to get
but it's a decision it's a process it
isn't something that somebody hands to
you
and so if you find that your life is a
misery understand that your life is an
exact reflection of your choices
and if you want a different life you
need only make a different choice
but i know right now many of you are
thinking but i don't know what way to go
i don't know what choice to make i don't
know what it is that i want to do
and as roy maurice keane said
i don't believe skill was or ever will
be the result of coaches it is a result
of a love affair between the child and
the ball
so ask yourself what's that thing that
you love
and don't judge yourself if it was
something that you loved as a child that
people are telling you you couldn't
possibly make money and it's that part
of the equation that i want to break for
people i want you to understand stop
asking yourself what you can make a lot
of money at and start asking yourself
what would you enjoy what is that life
that you don't need to escape from what
is the life
that is your love what is the thing that
as a kid you did whether people wanted
you to or not what is the thing you
would sneak out at night to do because
you weren't going to be stopped from
doing it everybody has something like
that in their life some spark of
interest may be long dormant maybe that
they've pushed aside because they think
it's stupid
or maybe they failed once and they think
they're bad at it
even though they love it
that sting of the failure
has convinced them to stop pursuing it
but at the end of the day the only thing
that matters is what gives you that
energy
at the end of the day the thing that
matters is what fills you with joy at
the end of the day the only thing that
matters it's not success
and it sure is hell isn't money
it's how you feel about yourself when
you're by yourself it's the things that
give you energy it's what you think
about yourself it's how you react to the
hard things it's whether or not you push
through
and when you push through when you
persevere when you go down the process
of taking the time to structure your
life
to build it into something that you want
it to be to build it into something that
you're proud of to become the person
that's capable of the things you want to
do that can first fall in love with
something and do it for the love of it
not worry about what other people think
if you hate your life i guarantee you
the thing is that you are trapped by
what other people think you don't want
to give it up because somebody will
think you're a failure you don't want to
give it up because it's a paycheck you
don't want to give it up because you're
scared
you're scared you don't know what you'll
do next
but imagine a world for a second where
all you thought about was what do you
love
what do you enjoy in that moment it
doesn't matter if it changes from day to
day just what do you love
what fills you with joy what gives you
that energy at the end of the day the
only thing that we all have is right now
this moment it's what you're
experiencing
loving what you
do how you spend your time
that's the point of all of it
the point of life is that
in each transient moment that passes by
doing something that fills you with joy
nobody can give you that
you've got to build that life
so go out
figure out
what it is that you want to do
and brick by brick
have the courage to build that life
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you
are awesome check out my lisa bill you
interview it's right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and i'll see you there part of
my own personal mission is to break the
idea that women should be any
right you should be an entrepreneur you
should be a mother at the end of the day
it really is what do you want to be